Am I dead not yet but you will
be unless you come with us
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
loki post credit scene video there's so many
things that they answered during this scene and
so many things that they set up it almost raises
more questions than it answers but we actually
have a lot of information about what's going on
here there are a whole bunch of easter eggs so
we'll break it all down if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
episodes we're doing a giveaway for disney plus
memberships i'll name a new winner at the end of
this all you have to do to enter that is just be a
subscriber and leave your favorite theory about
what's going on on this trash planet here of
course careful for spoilers for loki episode 4 if
you haven't seen the episode yet i'm assuming you
are if you're watching this video but in addition
to a bunch of big reveals about the secret of the
timekeepers the tva we also found out what it
seems like is happening with all the people in
the timelines that they've been erasing with their
wands in the time reset devices so it actually
goes deeper than this it's not that just other
loki's are being sent to this trash planet like a
cosmic version of sakar it's all the other loki's
but also things associated with those events like
that's how the avengers tower looks all ruined in
the background there because they erased it with a
time reset device and it got sent here there's
other trailer footage where you see this giant
ship drop down and land on the ground so clearly
more than just the loki's are being sent here when
they get erased also the reason why there are so
many other loki's here is because they want it to
be really cool moment like oh my god look at all
these comic book loki's but you'll also remember
the back during episode 2 mobius said more than
any other type of variant they're usually going
after loki's so that's why there's so many
loki's here disproportionate to other people
but talking about the other big reveals the other
big questions that they answer during the end of
this in the post-credits scene as a loki and
sylvie uncover the secret of the timekeepers
right at the end of the episode that they're
fake they're animatronic it seems like they've
been faked this whole time that's the implication
there were never any actual time keepers in the
story that miss minutes shows all the time
travel criminals in the history of the tva
is mostly fabricated this will be really important
in a second too though remember what loki said he
found out no one is ever truly evil and no one is
ever truly good so there's probably a little bit
of truth to miss minute's story about the history
of the tba but most of it is also probably fake
that also goes hand in hand with what's happening
with renslayer as well like renslayer seems like
she's really evil during this episode but as
loki said no one is ever truly evil or truly good
but then as part of this loki's redemption arc
his quest to not die alone thank you very much sif
he's seemingly about to confess his love for
sylvie and explain to her what he learned about
the nexus event that mobius was referencing when
he found them on lamentus lumentus1 it was all
about the coming together of two versions of loki
in a loving relationship like a true partnership
they did play those reveals during the episode
like everyone in the show those characters think
that there's a romantic aspect to it as well even
though in this interrogation scene loki tries to
deny it like i don't love her how dare you suggest
that renslayer runs him through and he goes out
hex vision style from Wandavision goodbye my
love in somehow winds up on this post-apocalyptic
amalgam version of earth it also renslayer then
tells sylvie just go ahead and kill me even though
she doesn't because she wants all the secrets tell
me everything i think renslayer did this because
she knows something about what happened to loki
because as i said no one is ever truly good or
truly evil that'll also go hand in hand with who's
really behind the tva itself like it's implied
that whoever's doing all this is evil but there's
the idea that no one is ever truly evil like they
have good intentions but they're doing really
evil things but the idea that renslayer knows that
everyone is a variant in the tva she also probably
knows about the stuff that they're erasing not
actually getting erased it's just getting thrown
in the cosmic closet so to speak like this trash
planet is the show's version of sakhar whether
it's a version of earth in a pocket dimension
whatever planet it is they're dumping stuff on
is where everything and everyone goes when they
get erased i think the idea though is that it
is a pocket dimension and these people who are
stuck here really are stuck here like they can't
go flying around anywhere in the universe that
they want but think of the metaphor of cleaning
your room when you're a little kid like your mom
tells you that you're gonna be in big trouble if
you don't clean your room up think of your room as
being the multiverse itself the sacred timeline so
instead of putting everything where it's supposed
to be because your room is a complete trash heap
you just throw everything in the closet and shut
the door and wipe your hands of it well job well
done see how easy that was that's exactly what the
tva is doing here they're just throwing everything
in like a pocket dimension like a cosmic closet
and it's kind of implied that they've been
doing it this whole time when loki asks himself
if he's in hell that's the asgardian version of
hell like i said in my last video we saw a version
of that when loki was looking into valkyrie's
memories during thor ragnarok it's kind of the
same trick that sylvie pulls on people when she
looks into their memories in the mcu hell hel is
just another dimension like valhalla another state
of existence then up walk the four loki variants
counting alligator loki as a distinct loki variant
too because he has the crown of horns on his head
and i know people want to call him croaky after a
crocodile loki technically he's an alligator not
a crocodile because they're two different animals
since the episode has come out too i haven't seen
anyone find any more specific references to
alligator loki other than to say it's just
another example of something like frog thor just a
loki who was either turned into an alligator or an
alligator who was turned into a loki if you want
to make a spider-ham reference from spider-man
into the spider-verse if you're not familiar
with his backstory the joke about spider-ham
is that he was just a normal spider who was then
bitten by a radioactive pig that's also kind of
what happened with frog thor in the comics yes
there was a version of thor that got turned into
a frog he referenced that during thor ragnarok
like loki turned me into a frog but also as part
of that story the original comic book story a
regular frog also separately gained the powers
of thor and wielded a version of mjolnir so during
that story frog thor was actually called throgg
that was the regular frog that gained the powers
of thor so it would be hilarious if this alligator
loki was just a regular alligator that somehow
gained the powers of a loki richard e grant is
playing classic loki with a costume based on the
original jack kirby journey into mystery loki when
he first appeared in the comics he's seemingly
way older than our main loki so it's not clear
what he did to create a nexus event but he's got
this little bag of supplies that he's carrying
here in the fact that he's working on a team with
these other loki's implies that he's not the one
that's behind the timekeepers of the tva reveal
he's just another victim of the tva i'm assuming
based on his scene here the way they're presenting
him unless there's some other more evil version of
loki that's played by richard e grant out there
he's just meant to be a cool cameo scene amidst
all these other cool versions of loki from the
comics boastful loki has a hammer here like he's
a big badass version of loki it could be a version
of mjolnir like this is what the hammer looks
like up close behind the scenes he just seems like
he's built to be another thor like version of loki
wielding a hammer he's super jacked like you would
expect a version of thor to be he's being played
by deobia oparei who most of you might remember as
ariel hoda from game of thrones they kind of did
him dirty during season five but he's a huge dude
in real life there's no big comic book references
to his character that we know of so he's probably
just meant to be a badass version of loki that the
tva just probably thought was too dangerous to
allow to exist inside the sacred timeline then
there's kid loki from the comics who winds up
being a more redeemed version of loki working
with the young avengers helping save the universe
before he gets co-opted by the original evil loki
and steals his body he's being played by jack
veal so kid loki is just meant to be another more
heroically aligned version of loki a more redeemed
loki and because this is meant to be the loki
series version of sakhar like a garbage planet
where all the cosmic trash gets sent all the
timeline trash gets sent that the tva is erasing
from timelines there's also going to be other
loki's here too like this confirms why president
loki is here and potentially other loki versions
president loki is just the other biggest version
that we know about from the trailers that we
haven't seen in an episode yet also this kind of
explains what's going on with the avengers tower
in the background like this might have been from a
version of the original avengers movie where loki
wound up defeating the avengers in new york city
in general just wound up getting trashed even more
but it just seems like our loki then teams up with
these other loki's you see this fight scene with
boastful loki fighting in our loki kind of ducking
behind him here remember per the rules established
on the show earlier no one is ever truly good or
truly evil the early theories just based on the
way they're presenting this end reveal here i know
people want another loki to be behind all this but
the other best theory that i've seen is that it's
really miss minutes this running thing so to speak
someone would have had to create her originally
and she was probably built for the express purpose
of preventing another multiverse war but think of
her as like a less overtly evil version of ultron
a living machine living digital consciousness as
she told loki she was alive and she kind of hinted
that she was always watching him and what have you
seen on a lot of those propaganda posters around
the tba the timekeepers are always watching and it
looks completely sinister but i use the heimdall
example like heimdall is a demigod he has the
ability to see anything in the universe but even
though he's a demigod he's super powerful he can
only focus on one thing at a time if you wanted to
monitor every potential threat to the multiverse
to the sacred timeline what better to do that than
some glorified algorithm or a computer program
monitor everything in the past present and future
all simultaneously the only other being that would
be powerful enough to do that would be someone
like the beyonder the one above all and those
probably aren't going to be characters that you
see on this tv series but i do like the idea that
miss minutes has sort of become the worst possible
version of something like a hydra algorithm from
captain america winter soldier so what did the
hydra algorithm actually do during that movie it
was built to monitor threats to hydra so think
about it this way miss minutes built to monitor
threats to the sacred timeline but just like the
hydra algorithm miss minutes starts to go minority
report having a lot of people erased before they
ever potentially commit crimes which sort of goes
hand in hand with what happened with sylvie like
she's just sitting there playing with her toys
what was the nexus event that made you erase my
timeline and they never answered that question so
i like the idea miss minutes may have just thought
that she might become a threat and then ordered
that the other hunters like hunter a23 whose goku
and bottom raw's character go after her arrest
her but in keeping with the idea that no one is
ever truly evil even miss minutes potentially or
gugu m'batha-raw's renslayer character they're
not killing these potential threats to the sacred
timeline they're just putting them in a permanent
cosmic timeout closet you go to this alternate
dimension where you can't cause any problems
for all time always so you have to imagine that
if sylvie had not escaped like she hadn't stole
renslayer's pad and gone on the run doctor
who style then she would have also got sent to
this junk planet but the big question now though
with two episodes left is what's gonna happen to
all these other loki's once our loki and sylvie
complete their mission of stopping the tva from
doing this anymore the early theory is they're
just allowed to exist go do whatever they want
more free will pursue their own lives without fear
of retribution unless they start committing some
acts of evil like the ones that survive the finale
don't get a total free pass and there will be a
loki season two so any number of these alternate
loki variants who survive could always come back
but when you're thinking about big villains what
could possibly be more evil than an algorithm
it'd be like saying the google algorithm which
is built to make people's lives better through
its actions even though it wasn't intentional
on google's part winds up being kind of evil
if you watch my westworld episode videos they
kind of did this with the main villain or main
antagonist on westworld where it wound up being
like this giant digital consciousness which was
preemptively controlling people's lives like the
mcu's version of minority report so everyone just
post all your theories after episode four do
you think this is a minority report situation
i will do a loki episode 5 trailer video tomorrow
and also if you didn't see it there was this huge
spider-man no way home reveal of a couple of his
new spider-man suits during that movie so i will
do a breakdown in easter egg videos for those make
sure you have alerts enabled for my channel so you
don't miss any of those and congratulations to
the giveaway winner for my last big marvel video
arthur d gastino please email me on the about
page of my channel so i can get your contact
details everyone click here for my full loki
episode 4 video and click here to learn about
the brand new Wandavision post credit scene that
marvel swapped in on the dl and all the changes
that they made thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!